hi everyone we are a group NASA
astronauts my name is Chris Hadfield
Vila Nova during manager here mae
Jemison jeff hoffman
mike massimino nicole stott we're here
to answer the top 50 movie questions
about space according to Montalvo there
we go Jeff asked us some questions birds
fly inside a space great would never end
no why was NASA created to beat the
Russians
that was a scream nobody name is in the
Big Bang how much is a space shuttle way
quarter million quarter million
excellent that's what the crew onboard
that just eight days yeah yeah how fast
is the International Space Station or
does the temperature in outer space
no well temperature in are actually in
space has no meaning because it's a
vacuum can you sure why I'm what is the
Goldilocks zone not too high in size yes
right
orbits the earth what your that was
Moore's name by not by the Romans
what is it cosmonaut Russian astronaut
teenage in space yeah what is the
strangest one well something that goes
and looks at other planets yeah
where is Kennedy what is space-time it's
a theoretical way to explain the
universe can we live on Mars is the more
young how are we in something very far
black because no there's nothing to
reflect the light let me tell you the
real answer because the agent sighs the
universe you only see light that has had
time to reach us so it's black it was
the first woman in smell analogy between
Mars and Jupiter
when Mars discovered we don't know for
recorded history
what does orbit mean means to go around
[Music]
do you see the Great Wall of China from
space when can you see Mars at night at
night at the right time who was the
first American in space separate those
Mars having a piano yeah and who was the
first man in space
God how long does it take to get to
space nine minutes it is friends on the
ship
where's National Space Station Hey ah
trick answer how long is a year on Mars
to our peers how much money to access
well it's not bigger than is why is Mars
red iron on our last night how many
satellites orbit the earth there's lots
space of vacuum yes yes what's the
temperature on Mars
50 60 degrees during the day and a
couple of hundred degrees below we have
our winner of new gemstones in space how
to become an astronaut like what is an
asteroid is an asteroid will be smaller
than a bionic number four is no way for
North we don't know yeah once we get
there not yet
how many moons does Mars have to toss
demos but it was not sustained for
National Space Administration sorry that
so many people have to ask that and
number one how long does it take to get
to Mars well it depends six months
anywhere from six to nine months someday
we'll be able to do it a lot faster did
you notice how US astronauts did this we
went five four three two new questions
nice work nice work